well the only thing I directed my cell
phone was had vaguely angry inch and
that was very hard to do two at the same
time too it was also writing so it was
you know was too many hats at the same
time um but I had to do because i had
written it for myself and there was a
sense of inventing as i go along because
i hadn't really done it before the
directing side i'd played the role
before on stage was less interested in
that but sort of had to do it um and ID
get all excited about the direction and
forget that i'd have to go on in front
of the camera which was irritating
especially cuz i was in drag and i had
to get all that together so there were
very long days we had a big short shoot
um but i ended up having to watch a lot
of stuff and play back to see if it was
working stuff that didn't know like a
close-up of myself i could tell what i
was working or not just internally so i
didn't need to look at that but the big
picture stuff and it was really
exhausting and i don't think i ever want
to do that again but it taught me stuff
that I you know can use to this day in
in knowing all the angles of filmmaking
and I guess actors really trust me as a
director because I know what they need
you know having been one but also having
worked with a lot of different people
with different processes and the acting
I kind of you know I did it for about 20
years professionally and kind of burned
out on it but lately couldn't wanting to
feel those you know like I said those
cells working again and i'm sure i'll
let it go again and do something else
end up writing a novel or something
well the understanding that their
partners and not just pawns you know
that they have different processes from
each other and from obviously other
artists and craftsmen I think of actors
most actors are craftsmen you know they
they know how to build something but
they're not necessarily creating the
elements that you're building with like
they don't you know they didn't create
the tree you know from scratch they put
things together and there's a small
special minority of actors that I think
our artists see what they add to it is
pushes it into the realm of art maybe
those actors tend to be more
self-directed you know some actors
really need to be directed and edited to
be their best and others are can create
something of a whole cloth so in a way
they're they're editing themselves
they're writing a bit for themselves are
directing themselves and can make
themselves their performance into a kind
of a sculpture that can stand on its own
we've all seen films that the writing in
the direction leave a lot to be desired
one of performance is quite stunning and
can stand alone as a kind of a sculpture
but actress you know are often
suspicious of directors because
directors tend to be afraid of them
they'd you know it's the unknown
quantity it's the immeasurable you know
non-technical element the talent that
they they tend to either just kind of
not direct them at all and just hope you
know something say faster or funnier or
something I think the best directors of
actors were actors or they've acted
themselves maybe taking a class or two I
think that you know the best way for
director to find out about that process
and not be afraid of it is to take an
acting class for four period of time you
know for a few weeks to see
the excruciating you know position that
an actress the actors are often in and
realizing that you know let the actress
instincts be the first order of business
don't over direct them too early when
they're going in the wrong direction to
know how to say very little to push them
in the right direction not over during
well there's a lot of actors that our
self involved you know which is
understandable there's a kind of you
know they are there they're tools and
get forget that there are other people
involved in a project and you know they
they appreciate actors that understood
don't aren't as needy you know that that
aren't bringing their personal lives
into the set because it's very difficult
to be emotionally available all the time
and yet tough enough to deal with
constant rejection and and constant
objectification you know and a lot of
actors can get very caught up in what
they look like and aren't you know the
lack of creativity between jobs you know
the best doctors that I'd like to work
with have other creative interests you
know there are writers or musicians and
they don't they look at acting as
another very special but it is just
another job I mean they should be you
know no better than the other craftsmen
on treated no better than any other
craftsmen on seven but the they're
usually called a lot a lot more because
they're the cameras on them and the
don't get caught up in the you know in
the money the fame the way the way they
appear to the world and generally
theatre people who grew up in the
theatre or work develops in the theater
are the easiest to work with because he
understand and part of a whole they go
to work regular hours they're team
players